had an appointment with my oncologist today, he gave me just months to live.
Okay, so that bothers me right there. It bothers me multiple reasons.
It just hurts me horribly. It hurts me horribly that somebody would even say that. How do they know?
If they think, oh boy, we just did a scan and it looks really bad, you don't, you just say,
okay, this looks bad, we need to change something, we need to do some things, but if he hasn't
no other tools in his tool bag, then he needs to say, okay, I don't have any tools in my tool bag
for this. Here's one I can offer, look at other things, you know, talk to your alternative doctors,
good as things. I just hate it. It just hurts me when you hear things like that. They don't know
things. Here's your Bible verse right here. God's word is alive and active and sharper than any two
inch sword that your oncologist might use to hurt you and even if you have four months to live,
five months to live, ten months to live, that's not for somebody to say, how do you know? How do they
know? They don't know. They're not God. God is God. And you might, you know, I might get run over,
driving home today. My faith has got to be in him, in him alone, not in some lab tests, not in some,
you know, therapy that they have or don't have to offer. We have to trust in that alone.
Okay, changed my chemo and may have radiation on my hips. By right side towards the
sign of my rib cage, I have pain when I take a breath, a deep breath. So probably something in your
ribs, for sure, hurts at night. Of course, so could be inflammation in your ribs and in the
muscle, in the intercostal muscles as well. He said there can be a glove like a rod deliver,
is there some way to relieve this? Yes, one, one cancer has matched the bones, can it ever heal?
Yes, we probably have people on this call that have had cancer to the bones, maybe not
from this call. I can't see everybody who's out here. That, you know, have been alive for years,
you know, I have patients that have been with me for over 15 years now, and we're in this situation
when they came to me. He thinks it's in the bow marrow. We'll send the cheek swab. Is there a way
to beat this cancer? He's never, never give up. You just keep doing things. You keep changing things.
You keep making tweaks that you need to make that is going to be best for you.
Make sure we talk tomorrow. So call me. We're going to get out of this schedule so we can
talk tomorrow and just don't give up. Whenever you hear bad news like that from somebody who's
touting bad news, please, please, please, everybody listen to me. You got to say in the name of Jesus,
I'm not going to accept that. God knows my outcome. He knew me before I was born, before I was put in my
mother's womb. He knew me and he knows all the days of my life are numbered by him. So I'm not going
to accept that. I'm not going to accept that at all. That's that I'm going to, you know, think
that I'm going to overcome it myself, but I'm going to overcome anything that God has for me
through him. So make sure you put that out of your mind.